our next caller is our friend Manu hey
Manu Manu Welcome to our
program hi good evening up how you doing
good thank you uh you started the show
by about the name of Jesus and uh I I
was excited because uh that was the
point that I was contemplating today in
terms of uh making comments about yes
get us get us back on track Manu yes we
want to go back to Jesus Islam Christian
Perspective so go ahead friend yes um
you you mentioned you mentioned the uh
book of Isaiah 9 yes and about the uh
and you brought that those verses to
show the name Prince of Peace umis
Mighty God uh Eternal Father all
those
um what I was thinking about today was
that
actually the name of Jesus was not given
by Mary or anybody else it was given
uh in Luke it says that the name of
Jesus was delivered to Mary MH and it
wasn't of original or it wasn't
originated on Earth nobody gave him that
that name the angel said that you will
call this child this name
Jesus okay also uh Quran itself says
that the Quran says that the name that
Jesus is given is from God H and it's a
different name in the Quran
just let make this before we go to and
yes talk about want to see where he's
getting to so um I I believe there's a
connection between the name Yeshua and
Yahweh yes there is if I'm not mistaken
sure and that really ties into the
prophecy of Isaiah which Quran calls the
yasa the name yasa is actual actually
Isaiah okay and the vers is that it in
Isaiah 9 20 or six onward yes so if we
see that it says that his name will be
called all those names okay it doesn't
indicate anything about Divinity of
Jesus as far as I can I can see it show
it just shows his name will be called
synonymous with Yeshua which is very
close to Yahweh only problem where am I
in error okay you're in error because
you didn't finish Matthew
1:21 uh the very passage that you're
refer referring to Matthew 1: 211 the
angel tells Joseph she will give birth
to a son and you shall call his name
Jesus and then he explains why the very
next sentence explains why because he
will save his people from their sins the
reason why Jesus is given the name
Yeshua because Yeshua is an abbreviated
form of yosua which means Yahweh is
salvation so the angel says the reason
why you are to call him Yahweh is
salvation because he is the savior who
does what the Old Testament says Yahweh
does save his people from their sins so
actually if you're going to argue from
the New Testament the very name of Jesus
indicates that in his case and I want to
emphasize that the reason why he's given
that name is to indicate His function
and nature as God who saves that's
Matthew 1:21 you read it if you have
your Bible open it up she will give
birth to a son and you will call his
name Yeshua because and he gives the
reason for the name he will save his
people from their sins now Manu if you
cross reference that with Psalm 130 and
you read verses 7 to8 do you have a
Bible with you Manu yes I have okay turn
to Psalm 130: 7 to8 according to the Old
Testament who saves Israel his people
from their sins Psalm 13:
78 oh Israel put your hope in Yahweh
when you see the word Lord all capitals
that's Yahweh for with Yahweh is
unfailing love and with him is full
Redemption he himself will redeem Israel
from all their sins Yahweh is the one
who saves his people from their sins but
the angel says Jesus is called Jesus
because he comes to save his people from
their sins which according to the Old
Testament is something that God does so
do you believe that Manu I just want to
add one more thing before you answer
Manu if you look back at the passage
that Sam and you were quoting there in
Matthew chapter 1 when uh that says that
the name of G it should be called Jesus
she will bring forth a son they shall
call his name Jesus Matthew 2 uh Matthew
1 verse 21 and then it says the very
next verse look at verse 22 now all this
was done now that refers to everything
before that and what immediately
precedes that now all this was done was
that the naming of this child would be
Jesus and Sam is is pointing out that
this Jesus uh is it means Yahweh sa in
fact if you continue see you're going to
see that Matthew identifies Jesus as God
With Us well that's what I'm going
to so verse 22 now all this was done
that why that it may be fulfilled which
was spoken of the Lord by the prophet
saying Behold a virgin shall be with
child and shall bring forth a son and
they shall call his name Emmanuel which
being interpreted is God with us so
understand Manu that uh this Jesus that
it was done so that it might be
fulfilled because calling him Jesus in
this case h the understanding is yes his
name was Jesus but his name wasn't uh
Emmanuel in the sense that oh everybody
called him Emmanuel but he was known as
Emmanuel because he's God with us and
then these same uh titles that you
referred to in Isaiah 96 and 7 this
isn't his specific name people didn't go
to down the street when Jesus was there
and just say hey there's Mr Wonderful or
there's Mr counselor uh these were
actually descriptions of who this person
was the Mighty God the Everlasting
father the Prince of Peace God With Us
and you'll find that testimony
throughout the New Testament manua we
don't want to overwhelm you because we
do want you to interact but let me
further confirm that as far as Matthew's
concerned now you may reject Matthew
that's okay and we'll talk about the
evidence why you should accept Matthew
but he just said if you continue reading
from 2123 two things happen Jesus has
called Jesus to indicate his nature and
function he's Yeshua because he's the
one who comes to save his people from
their sins by being born of the Virgin
he's Emanuel meaning God With Us that
Matthew is presenting Jesus as God who
has come to live with us you don't need
to uh stretch things or go to
commentaries you read Matthew himself
Matthew ends his gospel the way he
starts it in Matthew 28:20 Jesus quoting
Jesus he ends the gospel the way he
starts starts it notice how he started
it Jesus's birth means that Emanuel has
come God is now with us because Jesus is
Yahweh who comes to save his people
Matthew 28:20 and teaching them this is
Jesus speaking to obey everything I have
commanded you and surely I Jesus is
speaking am with all of you always till
the very end of the age Jesus is saying
I will remain with all of you till the
end of the age well the only way Jesus
can say he can be with all the Believers
at at the same time no matter where
they're at is if Jesus is omnipresent
but to be omnipresent you must be God
because only God sees everything and
superintends everything so that no
matter where you're at God is there he
sees you and he'll protect you if you
belong to him so Matthew begins with
Jesus being Yahweh who saves God who is
with us and he ends the gospel the same
way Jesus Remains The God Who is with
this people Till the End of the Age so
if you're going to go by the gospels
you're going to have to accept the fact
that the Gospels present Jesus as the
human appearance human manifestation of
the god of Israel